moscou dans le viseur de bruxelles
l'union européenne envisage de sévir
contre la russie à la suite de
l'arrestation et de l'emprisonnement
d'alexei navalni l'opposant russe arrêté
à son retour dans son pays en janvier
doit faire face à la justice et accumule
les condamnations lui évoque une
politisation de cette justice et exige
sa libération
les européens pourraient donc actionné
ce lundi leur nouveau régime de
sanctions des droits de l'homme la
décision sera prise au cours d'une
réunion des ministres des affaires
étrangères à bruxelles et les mesures
seraient effectives pour le sommet
européen des 25 et 26 mars
les sanctions européennes consistent
généralement une interdiction de visas
et un gel des avoirs dans lieu pour les
personnes ou les entités ciblées en
novembre 2020 alexeï navalni avait
demandé aux députés européens des
mesures plus concrètes
l'union européenne devrait cibler
l'argent les oligarques pas seulement
les anciens oligarques
mais les nouveaux membres du cercle
proche de poutine tant que les yachts de
monsieur ousmanov continueront à
mouiller à barcelone ou à monaco
personnes en russie au kremlin ne
prendra les sanctions européennes au
sérieux l'entourage d'alexei navalni
aurait soumis à bruxelles des listes de
personnalités supposées proches du
président vladimir poutine
l'adoption de sanctions nécessite
l'unanimité des 27 mai lieu reste très
divisée sur l'attitude à adopter face à
la russie la crainte de sanction
réciproque et d'une escalade des
tensions poussent à la prudence
il n'est guère possible de sanctionner
les oligarques
nous ne pouvons agir que contre des
fonctionnaires et cela uniquement si
nous avons des preuves de son côté
moscou espère qu'il n'y aura pas de
sanction à son encontre
nous espérons que le bon sens de la
situation prévaudra la conversation sur
les sanctions
malheureusement se déroule à bruxelles
elle se déroule aux états unis avec une
persistance absolument maniaque
c'est ce que nous n'accepterions pas
c'est ce que nous n'aimerions pas la
russie n'est pas le seul pays visés par
de possibles sanctions de l'union
européenne
l'emprisonnement de journalistes en
biélorussie pourrait également être
punis mais trois vagues de sanctions ont
déjà été adoptées par l'ue eux contre le
président alexandre loukachenko inscrits
sur liste noire sans aucun effet les
européens souhaiteraient également
prendre des mesures appropriées contre
le coup de force de l'armée en birmanie
enfin de nouvelles sanctions contre le
venezuela et la politique menée à hong
kong par la chine seront également
discutés par les ministres européens